you and i have talked about anxiety um
how have you managed this during
quarantine because everybody's kind of
managed it differently i've been writing
a lot
so that's awesome yeah yeah it's
interesting for me
you know i i've always dealt with
anxiety so going into locked
even hypochondriac which is great for a
pandemic
and my old sort of techniques of like
meditation and and the barns always
amazing but it just
i was still having a lot of anxiety if
i'm being honest
and i started listening to music as sort
of when i couldn't drop into meditation
i'd put on a record
started listening to music and just
wanting to listen all the time and i
started thinking about sort of the
relationship between anxiety
mental health and creativity and how
healing is creative
and creativity is healing and then that
led into this new podcast endeavor
about the power of music it's called
harmonics right yeah it's called
harmonics and
so what exactly happens on it so
basically um i i talked to
like glennon doyle who wrote untamed i
love
girl i'm a cheetah i'm a cheetah i'm a
cheese
she's the first episode oh you can
listen and she's
incredible um and brandi carlisle who
did i love that duet you guys i've never
been more vain i've never listened to
myself
more you do have the best voices of all
time and putting them together
i've listened but i've played that video
over and over again i told brandon i'm
like a millionaire
but um i wanted to ask people in the
music industry but also people like
london doyle women
how they handle this time mental health
what's happening in the world the
division in order to bring people
together
promote love and hopefully provide some
sort of healing
yeah and selfishly i get to ask people
like you all the questions i want to
know about what do you do for your
mental health on a day when you don't
want to get out of bed this is an
awesome
podcast i would love to have you on i
would love to come you know you should
have two
another glenn and doyle type figure is
brene brown oh
i love her her podcast is amazing yeah
ted talks yeah
ted talks too yeah everything yeah i
would love i have a i have a dream list
this is season one i have like
my dream list but i have really you know
music and an important feeling
i mean and writing is have you been
writing music or podcasts i literally
don't know how anybody goes through
anything horrible bringing their life
without having an outlet like i have
with writing
like even if it doesn't i was telling i
was talking to going the other day on
the voice and i was like
we're both writing right now for next
albums and it's like even if no one
hears it it's so therapeutic it's so
good for
you just that's your outlet and it's
almost like you know whether you're
religious or not or spiritual whatever
you believe there's something about that
you're giving that gift
of your writing even if nobody ever sees
it and it's a little like marie kondo
too you're letting it go
like thank you for the experience i'm
done yeah yeah totally and i'm terrified
for this podcast because i'm usually
like the girl twerking upside down on
television and like
falling down the stairs that's me and
there's room for all of it beth
but i realized that like if i expect my
guests to come on and not talk about
you know not just the classic sort of
interview questions if i want
them to get vulnerable and honest then i
had to and so
i i've revealed some stuff and talked
really deeply about my mental health but
then hearing like
that other musicians that i admire have
panic attacks before they go on stage or
something
oh my god especially musicians yeah i'll
talk through it
randy and i talked about what she's
saying for joni mitchell and how
you know i just started sweating for her
right now
wow but if she can get through that i
can get
you know there's something about coming
together and speaking about mental
health openly which for so long
especially as women were like i can
toughen up you know i can i'm going to
take care of my family i'm going to take
care of everybody around
it's all in that book i know i know uh
so yeah it's been amazingly healing
selfishly for me but also i hope it
helps
other people
you